yeah but we have a really close
relationship with Tom Holland we love
him
[Music]
you know we fought for him in casting
and you know it was a very specific
interpretation of that character because
Spiderman was my favorite character
growing up and to take him on that
journey we knew it was gonna be
heartbreaking cuz heartbreaking for us
and you know I'm sat watching it I was
tearing up because you know again that's
my favorite character and I had a
feeling that would translate in a way
that would be very painful everyone else
I thought well if this is and this is
hurting us watching it then we're going
in the right direction because this is
the point of the film is that you know
sometimes villains win
hey everybody is Charlie so you've
probably seen some of the news about
them confirming which Avengers
characters are crossing over from
Avengers 4 to spider-man far from home
so we got to break this down if you're
brand new to the channel there's a new
round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this they finally made it
official we're gonna get some major
f-bombs during spider-man far from home
because Sam Jackson's Nick Fury is now
confirmed along with Cobie Smulders
Maria Hill so that already confirms a
whole bunch of stuff about what's
happening towards the end of Avengers 4
with those characters there was a big
question about what was gonna happen
with them going into phase 4 do they
even care about Maria Hill the
interesting thing though is that we know
that there's gonna be a list Avengers
characters crossing over as part of that
Sony Marvel sharing deal with the
character so this doesn't necessarily
mean that they're the only Avengers
characters crossing over I would
consider Nick Fury an a-list character
Maria Hill not so much the reason why
this is such a big deal remember that
speech that he gave to Captain America
during Winter Soldier where it was like
things aren't always black and white
sometimes you need to operate within the
margins and Captain America was all
about doing what he thought was the
right thing nobody spills the secrets
because nobody knows them all
you're wrong about me I do share I'm
nice like that
spider-man is the younger version of
that Captain America idealism he's
unabashed idealism
so imagine Nick Fury laying some of
those knowledge bombs on spider-man like
there are just some important lessons
that spider-man has not learned in the
MCU yet even that sometimes you need to
operate outside the law break the rules
in order to achieve true justice that's
what Nick Fury is all about achieving
the ultimate goal of justice but the way
he gets there seems a little bit shadier
than someone like Captain America is
comfortable with but just imagine a lot
of those moments with Nick Fury going
down the same way just a whole lot of
Nick Fury that doesn't have time for any
of spider-man's wisecracking your jokes
so you probably all seen the behind the
scenes pictures with Tony Stark
in the shield costume on the set of what
looks like the original Avengers movie
so this is a layer cake of Easter eggs
to dig into here like one it's big that
they're in the scene from the original
Avengers movie looking like it's right
after the Battle of New York they're
rounding up Loki but the Russos are
saying in real life like no this isn't
time-travel that's going on here there's
something else it's called be AR effing
technology then you see Tony Stark
walking around in different scenes with
a shield costume on that doesn't look
like a scene from the original Avengers
movie like this is new footage made to
look like it's happening during the
original Battle of New York so if you
have a new watching agents of shield in
present day they did bring back shield
but the main reason why they haven't
really addressed that in the movies is
because they haven't put enough distance
between what's going on right now and
what happened during Winter Soldier like
that was too big of a revelation for
them to just bring shield right back and
make it a really big thing in the
universe so as of right now if you're
assuming that the TV shows are still
canon to what's going on in the movies
like everything is connected then there
is a shield presence but it's managed by
the government and people like
Thunderbolt Ross like the head that's
seen during the Avengers Base when they
show up with vision where you get the
sense that Ross in this White House
committee spends a lot of
I'm armchair quarterbacking the stuff
that the Avengers is doing satellites
lost him somewhere over Edinburgh stolen
four of the world's most wanted
criminals you know they're only
criminals because you've chosen to call
them that right so god roads your talent
for horseshit rivals money it weren't
for those accords vision would have been
right here
I remember your signature on those
papers colonel that's right I'm pretty
sure paid for loss you have second
thoughts this was effectively war
machine quitting too so now he's on the
outs but anything that happened during
infinity war could be rolled back during
Avengers four just assume that because
Nick Fury and Maria Hill are going to be
doing shield related stuff to help
spider-man out during spider-man far
from home that there will be some sort
of balance restored to the way that
shield and these characters fit into the
larger scope of things given the fact
that the government is now regulating
superheroes samuel l.jackson and Marvel
explained what was going on with the
characters before this post-credit scene
with the Captain Marvel pager like they
roll in just as everybody is getting
snap sure doubt they're talking about
Black Widow all the people that they
have been working with and you get a
much better picture of how he's been
operating off of the grid since Winter
Soldier like all through the events of
Captain America Civil War he wasn't in
that movie because he was out doing the
same type of stuff the Captain America
was doing with his Secret Avengers after
they broke out of the raft so you have
Cap'n as Secret Avengers going around
dismantling arms trade tried to make
sure that alien tech like you see during
spider-man homecoming doesn't get into
the hands of really dangerous people
so he's jumping all over the world Nick
Fury and Maria hill have been doing the
same thing independent of Captain
America but also in conjunction so they
have their own missions that they go on
but they coordinate with cap when they
have information to share but they try
to keep things separate you keep
splinter cells so that the government
can't catch them and I was almost gonna
do a separate video about this because
it's really cool there was a big
revelation on the DVD commentary from
the Russos about what's going on with
Iron Man in that flip phone but the
Russos revealed that at the end of
Captain America Civil War when iron man
officially went on government payroll
like he saw
via Coors so now he's under government
supervision they clarified that Ironman
would never be a stooge for the
government so this whole time since the
end of civil war he's been pretending to
work for Thunderbolt Ross while at the
same time making sure that the
government can't catch Captain America
so even though they still have that
personal beef between them that they
need to settle in Avengers 4 he still
thinks that what cap is doing is right
trying to help the world out and he
doesn't want him to be captured so he's
been doing a really sly job of covering
Captain America's tracks wherever he can
to keep the CIA and the government
international agencies from tracking
them down so that's not necessarily
something that you would get from
watching infinity war like he has the
flip phone so it's like whoa why hasn't
he called him yet what's going on why is
this still a big deal they just want to
leave a lot of that resolution for
Avengers 4 so if you have all this
Secret Avengers stuff going on to the
background / the writers of these movies
it sounds like they're gonna fix things
during Avengers 4 so that Nick Fury can
take a lot of that power back officially
so that he can operate with more
resources and be more of an asset to
spider-man as he's going around the
world trying to track down this Loki
sinister six so I've already done a
couple videos about the characters and
the villains that they've announced for
spider-man far from home it's a version
of the sinister six without the full six
characters Mysterio is just the biggest
one they still have not confirmed Jake
Gyllenhaal yet but as part of this
spider-man is traveling around to Venice
Prague in London now they've been
shooting in London but the reason why
people found out that Nick Fury is gonna
be in the movie and Marvel officially
announced it is is that Sam Jackson was
in Venice taking all these pictures like
what is he doing there they finally came
out and were like okay yeah fine he's in
spider-man far from home it was a
costume video that I did a little while
ago I know a lot of you want to see
spider-man make his own suit in the
future I do that they're building
towards that but we just have to wait
for some more evidence from the set so
if we get any more pictures or any more
video that give us any ideas about
what's going on or what he's gonna be
doing with the next new suit I will
totally do a video for it click here for
that deleted Deadpool to x-men scene and
click here for that spider-man far from
home costume teaser thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]